how does LinkedIn work LinkedIn's recent
quarterly earnings taught 473 million
dollars up from 25 million five years
ago the 11 year old company claims more
than 300 million members worldwide a
third of them here in the US it makes
money in three different ways one job
seekers upgrading to premium
subscriptions unlike other social
networks people pay for special access
subscribers COFF up twenty to fifty
dollars a month to contact recruiters
directly about jobs they're interested
in and make sure their resumes rise to
the top of the pile
LinkedIn sees 44,000 job applications
passed through its site every day so
these advantages may help candidates
stand out to companies selling to other
companies and to users LinkedIn's no
Facebook or Google when it comes to ad
sales but the company's information does
allow for highly targeted marketing
campaigns ad sales brought in 326
million dollars last year accounting for
more than a fit of the company's 2013
revenues three recruiters buying access
to members data and caring for their
firm to get noticed
recruitment professionals pay thousands
of dollars each month to access
LinkedIn's databases once upon a time
only job seekers posted resumes online
but these days through LinkedIn top
companies can access potentially
suitable candidates who may not even be
looking for a new job this business area
known as talent solutions is the
company's golden goose bringing more
than half of Lincoln's revenues so it's
no surprise that the company hopes to
entice the rest of the world's three
billion professionals to connect so that
they too can be found online